let's go to a caller from Skype any time
we take calls from Skype it can be a
little bit risky I don't know why that
is but it sometimes is Skype caller
please tell us who you are and what's on
your mind today if me you can hear right
now
yes it is hey my name is Addison I'm
from the UK and I was just wondering
what your thoughts are on the increased
Twitter limit character count yeah some
people who don't know Oren parthy for
some users the limit will go from 140
characters to 280 although you know what
Addison I've not yet read for which
users like how will it be determined yes
I think I just hate to test Anette them
and we've selected users that have high
follow accounts and then eventually it's
going to roll out to everybody got it
okay listen I I don't really care about
the the count Twitter character limit in
the sort of abstract I think from a
practical perspective Twitter wars with
a hundred and forty characters are
pretty pointless like I've never seen
anyone convinced or had a big epiphany
to re-examine their political philosophy
because of a hundred and forty character
message that they received on Twitter so
if doubling it to 280 allows for maybe
more substantive discussion I'm all for
it I just don't know if it will Addison
I think it'll just be 280 characters
with which people can call me a Jew [ __ ]
instead of 140 you know yeah
unfortunately I think it's probably
gonna be the same it probably won't make
a difference yeah
now the eventually if you keep
increasing the character count like I I
do think that there is something whether
you like 140 characters or not that was
sort of the big thing with Twitter right
that's what differentiates it from other
platforms where you can write longer
messages so I do wonder if this is an
attempt by Twitter to try to do
something that seems sort of radical and
it would be in their world because it's
been 140 characters for so long but it
will actually make Twitter less
distinguishable from other social
platforms if you can write longer
messages wouldn't it yes an interesting
point I saw on the blog post that they
made about it but they've had a sort of
an emotional attachment to it but that
wasn't really a good reason to sort of
hang on so anymore no and I second the
main reason
I think the main reason they did it was
they said a lot of countries where you
have characters instead of letters they
were able to fit pretty much everything
they wanted to say or you know like
Chinese characters and things like that
and they hardly ever hit the character
can limit whereas in the you know
English speaking or you know letters
countries people would often hit the
character count so yeah that's I've made
more sense and that's more logical to me
than an emotional attachment for sure
but I do think that there is sort of
marketing value tied up in 140
characters all right Addison thanks so
much for the call we're in the UK are
you I'm in Sheffield at the moment um
thank you very much for taking my call
all right appreciate it very much hope
to hear from you again